I have a voicemail number that number is
two one nine to david p let's take a
listen to this voicemail that came in I
do I'm question about something he said
I believe was October fourth or total
trip this year but he said that if
someone votes for Trump it's either
because they're uninformed a copter or
mentally deficient and I understand
uninformed but my question is on the
carpeting doesn't using in calling Trump
supporters in complicated efficient
doesn't that further the divide between
left and right does not make politics
more polarizing than it already is and I
understand you're a rational thinker I
get that but that's what here so he
opens on this thank you listen you may
be right i this show is not done for
optics right so just because i think it
would be one of the worst imaginable
things for Donald Trump to be president
of the u.s. I'm not gonna pretend that
WikiLeaks didn't leak Hillary Clinton's
speech transcripts and that I I and
avoid talking about them because they
might hurt Hillary Clinton this is not a
show done for optics and if that's what
I think about Donald Trump supporters
that's what I'm going to say I am NOT
going to be ultimately responsible for
whether political polarization continues
although I don't deny that using that
language probably isn't going to bring
in too many Trump supporters to my side
or whatever uh but this is not a show
that I do for optics and I get it the
optics of me saying if you're voting for
Trump you must really be clueless it's
not good optics but I'm not running for
anything and I'm just going to call it
like I see it on the bonus show today
Germany will pay convicted gays 30
million euro then compact to compensate
men that were jailed for their sexual
orientation under historic law we will
also get a Lewis update I saw Lewis over
the weekend i'll tell you what Lewis is
up to and also I've got an alex jones
story for you that I think you will
enjoy david pakman.com slash membership
the bonus show is available every day
just sign up and you'll get instant
access